hey guys Ryan right here so today is
gonna be a special little road trip
video lauren gah hasn't been coming on
the channel that much she's been a
working actress lately that's why cuz
she's so busy making money I decided to
help her out today cuz her car broke
down but she has an audition with Peter
Jackson don't know what it's gonna be
maybe King Kong 2 or another Lord of the
Rings movie or all that it's my Chinese
voice 10:30 she said 10:30 Laura she is
she's coming Misgav returning to the
real rejection open I'm vlogging by the
way oh I thought we'd do a little vlog
dition experience
I like your audition is like in 20
minutes though and you took forever to
come out till we find out your Edition
you know what I mean it's like
everything just happens the way it's
supposed to happen just the way this
[ __ ] just cut me off without singling
it's not fine there are rules on the
road and he's not obeying them now he's
driving slow the ham blinking science
coming up the handling then we get some
reason means it's gonna turn right soon
and of course here's the red light it's
fine Nick the guy who cut us off
he got to go ahead he got to go ahead
what street we have to turn on
I can't make I can't make that this
[ __ ] truck is this
you know next time Lauren you gotta tell
me earlier
what Street we have to be on a lot of
red lights today BA oh we caught the red
arrow because of you you told me to slow
down and now I caught the red arrow no
you were going so fast you just sit on
your brains was it matter there's
someone in front of us anyone it's green
buddy
hello go
it's a [ __ ] green arrow he's not
going I feel like I want this audition
for you more than you want it for
yourself so long at every stop sign I do
because I have something called trauma
where stop sign incidents happen I
haven't been the same ever since I don't
look at my uncle the same way so how
about we don't take streets anymore and
we get on the [ __ ] freeway 405 405
during the lunch hour is usually okay
what the [ __ ] why are we why are we
stopping
no [ __ ] there's traffic more on your
audition started ten minutes ago
are we stalling you know you seem like
awfully relaxed for someone who has a
serious situation there's a car accident
who gets in a car accident a lot of you
will get in car accidents yeah died and
you're making fun of them I'm not making
fun if they died they probably deserved
it you are a terrible person I'm a
terrible person
who's the one who picked you up and
trying to take you to your audition
maybe it's changing realize in a
positive direction maybe he's like a car
guardian angel
[ __ ] you and your [ __ ] positive
[ __ ] oh yeah they they closed off
this yeah I don't know I don't know
Lauren can't you tell there are [ __ ]
cones there this is my gas money born
where the [ __ ] is this place it's it's
at a [ __ ] in-and-out no it's on it in
and out I can't slow down there's a car
like right behind us
there's a I'm gonna kill this car behind
me murder him and his wife I hope he has
a wife that I could murder over here
right here 45 minutes after your
audition this spot right here
that dude just totally jacked our
parking spot you didn't have your signal
on it doesn't matter I was clearly the
first one coming here I should have done
the [ __ ] party I want that parking
spot oh my god party's watching you you
can't burn there but the [ __ ] is wrong
with you you are the worst driver do you
realize that I would have done better
like taking the bus [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
sorry hey how'd it go
messed up all my lines and I wasn't it
connected
wasn't my fault well you didn't help you
were yelling the whole time or made me
feel bad
I'm sorry Lauren I I feel terrible okay
I'll make it up to you is that the same
guy the guy who was tailgating us that's
him right there
Rice's face that's totally him who cares
No one second one second one second one
second I said one second I don't know
let's just see where this guy goes for a
second he's turning on what are we doing
this is the red so I'm gonna put my
lights in there okay I'm gonna do it do
what I'm gonna kill this mother you're
not right here okay make sure the
Karsten
yeah we are you yeah no I definitely
interested cool things things by [ __ ]
fun I've worked it congratulations
alright haha what a good day today is so
recording